We suspected it for the last two days and
Republican Senate majority leader Mitch McConnell
is now admitting that Republicans do not yet
have the votes to successfully block impeachment
witnesses in the Senate trial of Donald Trump.
Now, yet is a key word. Remember that in the
past we've seen reports that Mitch McConnell
didn't have the votes to confirm Brett Kavanaugh
to the Supreme court. Brett, Kevin, eyes now
on the Supreme court. So anytime we hear from
Mitch McConnell that he doesn't yet have the
votes, we have to understand that that may
be a game that he's playing.
The latest word is that witness related votes
are going to happen on Friday in the Senate.
McConnell says, hopefully by then they will
have the votes. Remember that witnesses are
dependent on a a C, a simple majority in the
Senate. So you don't need two thirds. You
need just 51 senators to say we want witnesses.
That would be the 45 Democrats, two independent
senators, Angus King and Bernie Sanders and
for Republicans, we suspect that Mitt Romney
and Susan Collins might be two of those four
Republicans. New reports suggest there could
be many more Republicans planning to vote
for witnesses, but until they do it, we don't
know. And as I said yesterday, Republicans
are remarkably unreliable at doing the right
thing. So let's not speculate any further.
Let's focus on the facts and the reality of
a trial and witnesses. Trials should have
witnesses. 75% of the country wants witnesses
per a new Quinnipiac poll, which we are linking
to, Republicans have complained that they
have not seen any firsthand testimony of what
Donald Trump did and wanted to have done.
Donald Trump's former national security advisor,
John Bolton, is willing to testify and is
likely to say what he says in his upcoming
book, which is Trump told him to withhold
aid to Ukraine until Ukraine smears Joe Biden
publicly. That's a firsthand witness. He's
willing to testify. Republicans claim they
want firsthand witnesses, but they are trying
to block John Bolton from testifying. Republicans
started signaling their talking points to
argue against witnesses a few days ago. They
are three main talking points. Republicans
are using, number one, they've started saying,
well, after we do 64 hours of stuff, 24 hours
of house managers, 24 hours of Trump's lawyers,
16 hours of Senator questions, then we can
decide if we really need to hear more. And
the implication is it's all kind of the same,
right? 24 hours of Adam Schiff is the same
as hearing from John Bolton. It's just more
hours. Of course, this is part of the gaslighting
because John Bolton can actually tell us what
Donald Trump did.
This is incorrect. It's gaslighting, but they're
going to try it. Secondly, they are trying
a strategy of if Democrats get witnesses,
we get witnesses too because this can't just
be one sided. Now the determination about
who testifies shouldn't be about uh, the,
the party affiliation or which side wants
the witness. The question should be, are they
material witnesses? Republicans have signaled
that if John Bolton testifies, they might
want Joe Biden to testify. They might want
Hunter Biden to testify. This is gaslighting.
The Biden's have nothing to do with determining
the guilt or innocence of Donald Trump. Republicans
want to make it about Joe Biden, but it's
not. Bolton is a firsthand witness to what
Donald Trump did. Trump is on trial, not Joe
Biden, so that's the second gaslighting strategy.
They will try. Number three, Republicans will
say, Democrats could have called these witnesses
when they had hearings in the house. They
don't get to do it now.
Now, of course, that's illegally and historically
invalid. You don't have to call every in the
house the same that you don't have to call
every witness in a grand jury that you eventually
call in the trial. The Senate is a valid place
to call witnesses. They had the option of
subpoenaing John Bolton in the house. It could
have taken a year or longer for that subpoena
to work its way through the judiciary and
nothing would have happened. So that is a
misdirection. Those are the three most common
arguments that we're hearing from Republicans
against hearing from witnesses. Last thought,
let me go back to the beginning. Mitch McConnell
says they don't yet have the votes to block
witnesses. He has said this before and gotten
the votes. This could be a ploy to make it
look like they're really deliberating. Republicans
are really taking it seriously and really
thinking through do they want to have witnesses
and if so, which one?
And then when they say no on Friday, if they
don't get the votes, they can say it wasn't
a foregone conclusion. We took all week to
deliberate. We thought about it really hard.
We didn't think we had the votes, and in the
end we did. So I will believe that four Republicans
are going to vote for witnesses. When for
Republicans, vote for witnesses in the Senate,
which may happen on Friday. Tell me what you
think will happen. Will John Bolton ultimately
testify? Remember a Sunday is my birthday.
We are doing a huge membership special on
Sunday, February 2nd if you want to be notified
of this membership discount, which will be
a beautiful thing. We've looked at it very
strongly. A lot of people don't know about
it, but we're doing it again on our mailing
list at David Pakman dot [inaudible].
You put in your email address Sunday, you'll
get an email with instructions on how to take
advantage of this great membership special,